d'ailleurs
tiens bon allez tenter bras
remonte
t un russe ou quoi
allez prenez le ces enfants suivent un
entraînement calqué sur les forces
spéciales de l'armée russe leurs
instructeurs sont tous des spetsnaz les
fameux commando de choc tout juste
revenu d'opérations de nettoyage en
tchétchénie
ça fait monter l'adrénaline dans le sang
on fait ça pour le danger au nom du
retour de la grande russie ces enfants
vivent chaque été à moi d'en faire
un jeu de guerre sans limites pour
tester la volonté des troupes comme
cette traversée de rapines l'eau est
glacial et la plupart de ces enfants ne
savent pas nager aucun bouton cadavres
c'est raide il est capable quand j'étais
au milieu de la rivière j'étais
totalement sous l'eau je sentais que je
coulais j'avais de l'eau qui rentrait
partout je voulais faire demi-tour et
mais je me suis rendu compte qu'il
fallait absolument que j'aille du côté
de la victoire et je m'en suis sorti
c'est pourquoi on fait ça c'est parce
que ça nous fait plaisir aussi
quel enfant capitalisme normal vous
drainage et dans une rivière aussi
dangereuse camara commandant quel enfant
capitalisme pourrait faire ça
aucun
chez
moi que ce soit avoir de l'argent à nos
amis lyonnais alors
à 300 km de muscu cascade le plus grand
camp paramilitaire pour enfants en
russie un camp d'élite où les places
sont rares ces deux cents enfants ont
été sélectionnés après un temps
d'épreuve seuls les meilleurs patriotes
sont restés âgés de 6 à 15 ans ils sont
tous là pour un mois un mois au cours
duquel rien ne leur sera épargné
des vacances d'été qui ont des allures
d'autrefois celle de la grande époque
des pionniers soviétique les uniformes
trop grand et les armes viennent
directement des stocks réformée de
l'armée rouge offert par le ministère de
la défense et même par l'ancien kgb
cascades et aux mains d'anciens parra
d'afghanistan et de tchétchénie des
nostalgiques de l'armée rouge bien
décidé à restaurer l'honneur perdu de la
russie et de son armée en haillons
commandant de section les troupes sont à
votre disposition
les hommes de cascades dirige ses
enfants comme une armée
dans les rangs vous devez avoir les bras
serrés le long du corps c'est clair oui
camarade instructeur depuis que vladimir
poutine est au pouvoir les financements
de l'organisation ont doublé et le camp
d'élite fait des émules à travers la
russie plusieurs centaines de camps
militaires pour enfants ont ouvert en
deux ans encouragé par la nouvelle
politique d'état
leurs mères veulent qu'on en fasse des
hommes des vrais âge parce que 80% de
ces enfants n'ont pas de pair
ils vivent sans idéal masculin ils n'ont
personne finalement sur skis prendre
exemple
alors nous ici nous avons décidé
d'occuper cette place
pour tous ces enfants que nous sommes
des grands frères comme des amis mais
pour la majorité nous sommes surtout le
père qui n'ont pas une chose
on a nettoyé les armes elles brillent
orphelins ou élevés par des mères seules
souvent sans emploi beaucoup de ces
enfants côtoyer la drogue et la violence
dans la rue une enfance délaissé en
rupture une manne idéal pour des
militaires en mal de pouvoir qui en font
des russes à leur manière ici les petits
caïds de la rue apprennent à tirer avec
de véritables armes si mieux à 9 ans son
premier stage il l'a fait à six fils de
speed ce naze encadrés toute l'année par
les paramilitaires de cascades il n'a
qu'un rêve faire partie un jour des
troupes de choc en trois ans à peine il
est devenu l'un des meilleurs éléments
du camp un pur produit du système des
clauses ici on apprend à aimer la patrie
et surtout à la défendre coûte que coûte
on apprend qu'il nous faudra donner son
sang est peut-être même sa vie pour elle
je peux juste il faut la défendre contre
eux qui peut nous faut aussi violent
contre tous ceux qui lui veulent du mal
ceux qui veulent lui porter atteinte
ceux qui veulent nuire au peuple russe à
la population russe
qui par exemple
qui les combattants tchétchènes
et
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire avec eux
les mettre hors d'état de nuire
au fil des camps les mots de l'enfance
cèdent la place aux phrases toutes
faites de la propagande anton à 14 ans 4
en cascade avant ils passaient le plus
clair de son temps dans la rue et dans
les rixes entre bandes rivales d'une
cité de la banlieue de moscou récupéré
par l'organisation aujourd'hui ces
disciplines préférées sont le maniement
des armes et les cours d'idéologie
sous staline c'était bien mieux ça va
tout le monde avait peur les sportifs
s'ils perdaient une compétition ils
étaient fusillés et c'était la même
chose dans l'armée ceux qui désobéissent
ait été fusillé c'était bien pour ça que
l'urss était si puissante bien supérieur
à la russie aujourd'hui
pour les instructeurs de cascades
retrouver la grandeur de l' urss ses
formes et ses enfants soldats à l'esprit
commando une des premières règles
apprendre à tuer sans se poser de
questions
et regardé par ici voilà il faut
attaquer par derrière lui mettre un coup
de pied au bon endroit
ensuite vous ne tournez pas sa tête
comme ça parce que de toute façon vous
n'y arriverez pas mais faire ça
et ça suffit
hélas arrêtez de vous bousculer
et regarder toi essaient de résister si
je te prends comme ça tu ne peux rien
faire
c'est la même chose sur lui et voilà
et
vous là vous n'avez rien à faire
si ranger le territoire
allez allez-y il est où votre territoire
allez au boulot cette petite bande ce
sont les rebelles du camp il n'avait pas
demandé à passer leurs vacances à
cascades gamin des rues ou cas sociaux
ils sont venus de sibérie envoyé deux
forces par la mairie de leur ville ça te
plaît ici non pourquoi
nous on ne fait que ramasser leurs
poubelles
c'est ça qu'on est des ramasseurs de
merde
moi je veux rentrer à la maison
la première chose que je ferai la vraie
je mangerai et je retournerais dans la
rue m'amuser vivement la fin
liot chat vadim dimitri ont tous une
dizaine d'années déjà un casier
judiciaire habitué à la liberté des rues
cascade pour eux a des allures de prison
rétif aux méthodes musclées des
commandos ils sont devenus en quelques
jours les boucs émissaires du camp les
préposés aux sales besognes
moi je pensais pas qu être soldat ça
voulait dire être femme de ménage ouais
on fait que porter des planchers du bois
c'est dur là c'est
vraiment dur
on nous en voyons ici on nous avait
promis qu'on irait au parc d'attractions
gorki au mcdonald's est alors temps
comme on est allé nulle part on a eu une
explosion dans un monastère d'hommes en
plus
d'un bon les troupes
à l'est
il est 5 heures du matin
réveil brutal au son des canons et des
bombardements la guerre un bande
originale fille ou garçon qu'on est 6e
14 ans c'est le cauchemar quotidien de
ces 30 jours de camp
j'ai dit deux bouts elle est au pas de
course vous prenez vos armes ne dit que
ça allait plus vite
qu'est ce que tu fais là toi je me suis
fait mal à la jambe je t'avoue j'ai joué
ça m'est égal tu descends temps lui tu
prends ton armée tout haut mais dans les
rangs et plus vite que ça
et toi qu'est ce que tu fais là assis
par terre allez dehors dans les rangs et
au pas de course
et vous là qu'est ce que c'est que ça
encore je trouve que mon arme je crois
que c'est moi qui l'ait peut-être
les enfants au moins d'une minute pour
mettre leurs uniformes et trouver leurs
armes un rythme impossible pour les
gamins des rues de sibérie
l'entraînement du camp d'été est réputé
pour sa dureté et même les habitués ont
du mal
la majorité de ces enfants vivent toute
l'année scolaire au rythme militaire
trois fois par semaine à la sortie de
l'école et tous les week-ends ils sont
pris en charge par les mercenaires de
cascades ils apprennent le tir à balles
réelles à la kalachnikov et le maniement
des grenades et des mines et complète le
tout par des cours d'idéologie un
efficace lavage de cerveau seuls deux
enfants sur 10 arrive au bout des six
ans de formation du camp des luttes
il est où
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
il est où ton charger il s'est cassé
pourquoi il est cassé dur chez pas
nous a toujours pas prêt à tenir
correctement votre arme
toi la cantine toi aussi
et toi aussi
pour les retardataires pas de petit
déjeuner ils devront courir plus de 40
km dans la journée le ventre vide
le réfectoire est sous étroite
surveillance
pas de question de parler ni de rire
les enfants ont dix minutes pour avaler
leur ration et le régime est le même que
dans l'armée russe un bol de pâtes ou de
bouillie de semoule trois fois par jour
tu vas à la guerre
commença à presse on va devoir courier
40 km il y aura des obstacles des
ennemis partout ça promet d'être dure
c'est exactement les mêmes conditions
qu'au combat c'est pour ça qu'on est
camouflée comme ça
on est comme les pionniers toujours prêt
tout le monde est là tout le monde est
vivant
on souffre attention
maintenant on va attaquer le thème allez
on y va anto de même les trous but de
l'exercice prendre d'assaut un site
stratégique tombé aux mains de
l'adversaire et l'ennemi est désigné
d'office celle islamistes tchétchènes
qu'il faut anéantir par tous les moyens
le secrétaire et des instructeurs c'est
d'envoyer leurs enfants soldats tués du
caucasiens
et où cet [ __ ]
là tu vois là bas plus à gauche ah oui
je le vois on va lui régler son compte à
celui-là
le premier faut le prendre par surprise
et l'autre il n'aura pas temps de réagir
tu prends ton flingue tu fais comme ça
il y
[Applaudissements]
ils ont à peine 14 ans et on leur a déjà
appris à tuer les gestes sont précis ce
sont ceux des vrais mercenaires dans le
rôle du méchant à abattre les mauvais
éléments du contingent jugé trop belle
les petits de sibérie ont été désignés
d'office
même en russie le dressage des enfants à
la guerre peut choquer
que des enfants apprennent à faire la
guerre mais non c'est impossible chez
nous et toi le commandant qu'est ce que
c'est que ces enfants qu'est ce que
c'est que cette farce
je ne suis pas encore commandant allez
dites leur que c'est une farce estime
et de quelle farce parlez-vous qui parle
de farce
oui c'est vrai que vu ta tête ça a pas
l'air d'être une farce on ne s'occupe
pas de farce nous retrouver des choses
sérieuses ils disent que les enfants
prennent la guerre à
la guerre on les forme pour l'armée
ait pas fait voir
oui mais c'est pas des bêtises ça a
l'air sérieux tout ça
garde à vous
parallèlement aux jeux de guerre le but
de cascades est aussi d'inculquer la
soumission et pour tester l'obéissance
et tous les moyens sont bons
comme en nba ces derniers temps vous
n'en fait qu'à votre tête
certains dorment trop longtemps
d'autres ne sont jamais dans les rangs
quand il le faut et d'autres encore font
des escapades dans les magasins du
village voisin breton c'est n'importe
quoi
alors maintenant vous allez une petite
réserve de ce terrain it was
toute l'herbe pour que je ne vois plus
rien dépassé de plus de trois centimes n
compris
pourquoi je ne vois pas de visages
heureux
allez les gars souriez
le ritz et 20 mètres par heure
cet idiot leur truc il n'y a que des
débiles qui peuvent inventer des
punitions pareil les t bills
bon t'as une heure et demie pour poser
une fosse 1 m de large et 1 mètre
soixante dix de longueur
pour casser les plus rebelles les
instructeurs emploi tout le registre des
punitions militaires comme le port du
masque à gaz toute la journée par 30
degrés à l'ombre asphyxie garantie
notre but c'est de former des citoyens
normaux sains d'esprit ces enfants ne
seront pas tous des officiers des
défenseurs de la patrie mais ils seront
de vrais citoyens russes ont fait ça
pour le futur de notre nation et l'état
aujourd'hui nous soutient parce que nous
avons un but commun avec le nouveau
pouvoir celui de donner la renaissance à
des gens normaux nous en avons assez des
dépravés qui ne font que regarder mtv
mâcher du chewing-gum faire du
skateboard ou fumé de la marijuana
j'ai rien fait j'en ai marre j'arrête
tu fait une crise d'hystérie
remets ton masque
remettre un casque et essuie mois
diva a craqué pourtant en venant à
cascades il savait à quoi s'attendre
pour lui maintenant c'est l'humiliation
la honte suprême le renvoi
tu refuse d'obéir à l'ordre de creuser
t'as plus rien à faire ici battant tu es
viré
allez va faire des affaires
pour toi il a été puni qu'est ce qu'il a
fait il a refusé d'obéir et il a parlé
familièrement à l'instructeur
refusé de couper l'herbe
c'est n'importe quoi c'est dégueulasse
il n'a même plus à parler tellement
samedi couche
contrôle toi nous fait pas honte
dim a été volontaire mais même pour lui
l'ambiance du camp est devenu
insupportable
des vraies leçons c'est quand le
commandant est là dès qu'il s'absente
quelques heures ce sont ces crétins
d'instructeurs qui prennent le pouvoir
et des sadiques les pervers
ce qui est plus vite c'est aussi
une histoire qui
la perversion des instructeurs par effet
de mimétisme se répercutent rapidement
chez les plus jeunes
le binge et d'y
aller mais tes chaussettes
les petits soldats se transforme peu à
peu en chiens de guerre de tutos ces
bizutages eu mignon qui élimine les plus
faibles se font sous l'oeil bienveillant
des gradés a
tjrs un crétin pourquoi tu mets ton
béret sous ton casque est trop nul des
gages à lui au pas de course
le matage de la petite bande de sibérie
toujours en rébellion se poursuit
et pour ces gamins qui s'accrochent à
leur liberté se faire raser la tête est
une humiliation de plus
moi j'en peux plus je veux rentrer chez
moi ma ville me manque mary aussi
ouais là bas au moins on est libre on
joue quand on veut on dort quand on veut
ici non ici c'est sévère c'est ici si tu
voles par exemple il te casse le bras
[Musique]
non seulement ils te casse le bras mais
avant de renvoyer les instructeurs
rassemble tout le régiment est un par un
ils te mettent des coups de pied dans la
gueule
au camp c'est l'effervescence
boris galkin ancien para d'afghanistan
passé au cinéma après la guerre une
sorte de rendre des séries b en russie
est venue galvaniser les troupes
allez les paras sous le préau
le grand jour est arrivé vous avez
devant vous votre héros et le mien aussi
c'est grâce à lui que je me suis engagé
dans les paras c'est grâce à lui en fait
que nous sommes tous là aujourd'hui
la leçon du jour est entendue la patrie
château et ceux qui lui veulent du mal
je tiens à ce que vous sachiez que ce
que fait notre armée en tchétchénie ne
tolère aucun doute
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui un seul pays
dans le monde qui ne souffre du
terrorisme islamiste tchétchène
on ne peut pas négocier avec les bandits
il faut les châtier comme il se doit
s'il y avait des négociations ça serait
une offense
une honte pour la russie
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de russes ont donné leur vie
pour que notre patrie soit fier et riche
si on ne peut pas défendre l'intégrité
de la russie avec notre énergie physique
se met aussi spirituelle alors quelles
charges de citoyens sommes nous
il n'y a rien de dangereux dans le
patriotisme on essaie de faire passer ça
pour quelque chose de négatif du
chauvinisme mais moi je vous le dis le
patriotisme c'est bien chauvinisme
et l'endoctrinement de cascades au fil
des jours inexorablement façonnent les
esprits les anciens gamin de la rue se
découvre un nouveau rêve une mission
ici j'ai appris qu'il faudra qu'à
l'avenir je mette de l'ordre partout
je mettrai de l'ordre dans ma vie et
dans celle des autres je surveillerai
tout le temps ce qui se passe
je mettrai de l'ordre dans le pays
connaissent le coup moi je me sens
supérieur à tous les enfants de mon âge
du coup ils sont tous des dépravés
sur trente enfants dans ma classe on
n'est que trois à pas fumer
tous les autres ils se droguent boivent
de l'alcool
ce sont des bons à rien des toxicomanes
des nuls
tu te sens différent d'eux
je les regarde comme des minables qu'on
nous fasse des dépravés
nous sommes comme des sculpteurs avec
leurs oeuvres si l'artiste est bon
l'oeuvre sera réussi voilà ce que nous
faisons ici de belles oeuvres on façonne
ses gamins ont rempli leur vide
on fait quelque chose de grand je crois
qu'on peut être fier du résultat
comme à la caserne les petits soldats
ont le droit à une permission les 10 15
ans se rendent au centre aéré le plus
proche le petit lénine un ancien quand
pionniers
aujourd'hui une boum est organisé
pendant ces premières et unique heures
de détente on peut enfin regarder les
filles
l'uniforme des fils de cascades fascine
les gamins des villages voisins
à
quel âge on commence
à partir de 6 ans
et vous vous entraînez au combat combien
de fois par semaine
pour ceux qui habitent près de la base
c'est trois fois par semaine
tu devrais faire leur camp d'hiver ça
ferait du bien à toi même
c'est bien de venir dans des endroits
comme ça que des civils voit grand et
ressemble parce que si après une telle
sortie je reçois dix ou quinze lettres
de maire demandant que leur fils vienne
d'un cascades et bien on aura gagné on
sera de plus en plus nombreux et c'est
ça la propagande indépendante les avis
sont mieux classés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
sur la piste civile et militaire
fraternisent conquis par la lure des
régiments de cascades les gamins du
centre aéré leur demande d'un service
donné une bonne leçon à une bande
d'adolescents du village voisin qui les
rackettent depuis des semaines trop
contents les régiments de cascades
s'improvise miliciens ils s'arment de
manches de pioche et partent à la chasse
et pour cette opération très spéciale
interdiction de filmer
quand ils nous ont vus arriver ils ont
pris peur
et ils sont partis sans demander leur
reste
on a appris qu'ils avaient des couteaux
alors nous aussi on a pris nos armes
et voilà et les armes c'était pour quoi
faire vaut rien juste les intimider
on va leur régler leur compte qu'est ce
que tu as dit
on va aller tabasser c'est tout
à moscou au comité des mères de soldats
on s'inquiète face à la recrudescence
des camps paramilitaires pour enfants
signe évident d'une militarisation de la
société depuis l'arrivée de poutine au
pouvoir ici on est depuis des années les
mères sans nouvelles de leur fils en
tchétchénie et on lutte surtout contre
la didot china le sinistre bizutage de
l'armée russe qui fait des milliers de
victimes par an
on est catégoriquement contre le fait
que des enfants soient d'une manière ou
d'une autre on brigade est dans un
système militaire
c'est interdit par les lois
internationales c'est contre les droits
de l'homme
les enfants doivent avoir une enfance
normale ils ne doivent pas dès l'enfance
apprendre que quelqu'un est un ennemi et
que l'on ne peut défendre la patrie
qu'avec une arme c'est très dangereux on
va lutter de toutes nos forces pour que
ça s'arrête
non seulement c'est un retour en arrière
mais surtout ça signifie qu'on prive le
pays de son futur à prendre la cruauté à
des enfants les éduquer à la guerre ça
veut dire que la russie n'aura pas
d'avenir
repos
tout ce que je vois devant moi
aujourd'hui peuvent se considérer comme
de vrais soldats
parce qu'ils ont su donner tout ce
qu'ils pouvaient au service
ils ont enduré la souffrance comme il se
doit
aujourd'hui je n'hésiterai pas à partir
au combat avec ce que je vois dans ses
rangs parce que ce sont des soldats à
qui on peut faire confiance dans toutes
les circonstances et c'est ça le plus
important
[Applaudissements]
alors chef tu l'a attendu longtemps ta
médaille oui
je te félicite
je sers la patrie ses vacances
particulières sont terminées comme après
tout campagne militaire vient l'heure de
l'incontournable remise des médailles
dans un studio entonne va regagner sa
cité et fier de son grade il entend bien
faire régner l'ordre dans son quartier
simone persuadé qu'un tchétchène et
terroristes dès la naissance veut
désormais poser des bombes à grozny
les miliciens de cascades ont volé la
part d'enfance de ces jeunes est alors
de leur retour à la vie civile
les petits soldats sont persuadés de
faire partie des êtres supérieurs les
uniques gardien de la nouvelle russie
propre et fier de vladimir poutine
[Applaudissements]